Ahora vamos a ver otros ejemplos, de cómo
se resuelven ecuaciones, como puedes notar,
estas ecuaciones son un poquito más complicadas,
requieren más pasos para llegar al final,
a la respuesta, pero vas a ver que son muy
fáciles de resolver.
Ahora, algo muy divertido acerca de estas
ecuaciones es que hay muchísimos caminos
que puedes seguir y en todos ellos llegas
a la misma respuesta, que es la respuesta
correcta, eso claro, si haces puros pasos
válidos, o sea puras operaciones aritméticas
y todo lo que le hagas al lado izquierdo,
se lo hagas también al lado derecho.
Entonces, pues empecemos a resolver estas
ecuaciones, empecemos por resolver
"1.3x" menos "0.7x" igual a 12, ok.
Bueno, al menos el primer instinto que me sale a mi, es tratar de juntar estos dos términos,
o sea porque tenemos aquí 1.3 de esta cosa menos 0.7 de la misma cosa exactamente,
digo si quieres le podemos llamar manzanas o peras,
tenemos aquí 1.3 manzanas menos 0.7 manzanas,
entonces, porqué no agarramos y juntamos
estos dos términos, si quieres, puedes pensar
que estamos haciendo el inverso de la propiedad
distributiva de los números, ok, y el chiste
es que nos queda aquí 1.3 menos 0.7
por esta cosa de nuestras manzanas, ok.
Todo esto de aquí es exactamente igual a esto de acá y eso, pues según esta ecuación,
tenemos que es igual a 12, ok pero 1.3 menos 0.7, eso es 0.6 por nuestras manzanas,
nuestra "x", eso es igual a 12, ok.
Esta ecuación de acá es equivalente a esta
ecuación de acá, pero esta ecuación es
muy parecida a las que estábamos viendo en
el video pasado, o sea tenemos aquí nuestra
incógnita, nuestra variable "x", multiplicada
por un coeficiente y eso es igual a otro número.
Entonces nosotros sabemos que podemos simplemente
dividir entre 0.6 para que éste se cancele
con éste pero todo lo que hagamos del lado
izquierdo del igual
también lo tenemos que hacer del lado derecho del igual, o sea que aquí tenemos que dividir entre 0.6,
muy bien, entonces ya lo único que tenemos que hacer es resolver esta división
y ya tenemos a qué tiene que ser igual esta "x".
A ver, para resolver esto tenemos que
poner aquí 12 entre .6,
entonces movemos el punto decimal para acá, así es que tenemos que mover el punto decimal
un lugar para acá,  así es que le agregamos un 0,  por aquí ya está nuestro puntito y ahora sí,
¿cuántas veces cabe el 6 dentro de 120?
eso vale exactamente lo mismo que cuantas
veces cabe el .6 dentro del 12, ¿cierto?
Bueno, entonces 6 por 2 nos da 12, restamos,
nos queda 0, bajamos el otro 0 y 6 por qué
nos da 0, 6 por 0 nos da 0... 6 por 0... 6 por 0 nos da 0, restamos y tenemos residuo 0,
entonces el 6 cabe 20 veces dentro del 120 y, lo que es lo mismo, el .6 cabe 20 veces dentro del 12,
entonces 12 entre 0.6 es igual a 20,
así es que "x" es igual a 20, ok.
A ver, vamos a verificar nuestra respuesta y para verificarlo, lo que tenemos que hacer es sustituir la "x"
en cada uno de lo lugares de la ecuación en los que aparezca la "x", o sea, aquí y acá.
Entonces, nosotros tenemos 1.3 por "x", que
en este caso es 20 menos 0.7 por 20,  lugar
en lugar de la "x" y eso, queremos verificar
si eso es igual a 12.
Entonces 1.3 por 20, ¿sabes qué?
vamos a sacar la calculadora
para que no me veas haciendo tantas cuentas, entonces tenemos que 1.3 por 20 esto es igual a 26...
26...
esto de aquí es 26...
y luego le tenemos que restar 0.7 por 20...
0.7 por 20, eso es 14,
entonces esto de aquí vale 14 y claro que podemos hacer todas estas cuentas a mano,
pero me tardaría más y ya hicimos muchas cuentas a mano en este video y en el pasado.
Entonces 1.3 por 20 es 26 y a eso le tenemos
que restar 0.7 por 20 que es 14
y 26 menos 14 eso es igual a 12, así es que sí, en efecto, "x" igual a 20 si satisface esta ecuación, ok.
Porque cuando sustituimos la "x" por el 20,
sí tenemos que este lado de la ecuación
es igual a este lado de la ecuación, ok.
Entonces esta respuesta sí es correcta, así
es que podemos ir a la siguiente ecuación.
Ahora vamos a resolver, "5x" menos "3x"
más 2 igual a 1.
"5x" menos entre paréntesis "3x" más 2,
eso es igual a 1.
Tenemos que encontrar "x", eso se ve mucho
más complicado no, bueno cuando te encuentras
con ecuaciones complicadas, el chiste es hacer
algunos pasos, algunas operaciones que hagan
que la ecuación se vea más sencilla y no
importa cuantos pasos hagas, siempre y cuando
cada vez se vea más simple la ecuación y cada paso sea un paso que realmente podamos hacer.
Por ejemplo, aquí tenemos menos y un paréntesis,
eso lo podemos ver como un -1 por este paréntesis
y aquí entonces le tenemos que poner un más.
Y entonces, lo que podemos hacer es distribuir
la multiplicación de este -1 en este paréntesis.
También lo podemos pensar como que estamos
distribuyendo el menos.
Para que no se vea tan mal, vamos a quitar
lo que acabo de poner....
y entonces, lo que nos queda a la hora de distribuirlo es "5x" menos "3x" menos 2 y listo,
esta expresión es igualita a esta
otra expresión.
Entonces esto tiene que seguir siendo igual
a 1, ok, porque esto es igual a esto que a
su vez es igual a 1, entonces esto es igual a 1.
Y entonces ahora, tenemos algo que se parece
mucho a la ecuación anterior,
aquí tenemos 5 manzanas menos 3 manzanas menos un número igual a otro número y lo que queremos,
es llegar a una expresión de la forma "x"
igual a otro número.
Entonces, lo que podemos hacer es juntar estos
dos términos, tenemos 5 manzanas
menos 3 manzanas, esto es igual a 2 manzanas, porque
5 menos 3 es igual a 2
y tenemos -2 igual a 1 y ahora queremos
deshacernos de este -2
y la mejor forma que yo conozco para deshacernos de este -2 es sumando un 2, ok,
porque entonces este 2 se cancela con este -2 y nos queda simplemente el "2x",
pero muy importante, ¡muy importante!,
que no se nos vaya a olvidar
que todo lo que le hagamos al lado izquierdo, se lo tenemos que hacer al lado derecho,
entonces aquí nos falta sumarle un 2
y 1 más 2 es igual a 3,
entonces esta ecuación es la misma ecuación
que "2x" igual a 3, muy bien.
Aquí ya tenemos una ecuación muy parecida
a las del video pasado,
donde tenemos a nuestra variable multiplicada por un coeficiente igual a otro número.
Así es que podemos resolverlo muy fácilmente,
dividiendo entre el coeficiente que está
multiplicando nuestra variable
de los dos lados del igual, ok.
¿Y para qué dividí yo entre 2?
Pues dividí entre 2 para que este coeficiente
se cancele con este coeficiente y nos quede
simplemente la "x".
Y entonces nos queda "x" igual a 3/2.
Y listo, ahora te va a tocar a ti verificar
que esta respuesta "x" igual a 3/2,
sea una respuesta correcta, ok.
Y ahora vamos con la siguiente ecuación.
Tenemos aquí "s" menos 3/8 de "s"
igual a 5/6, ok.
3 por "s" entre 8, es lo mismo que 3/8 de "s".
Entonces, aquí tenemos que encontrar a "s"
y además tenemos una fracción por "s" y
una "s" solita, sin ningún coeficiente,
¿cómo le vamos a hacer?
Bueno, pues le vamos a hacer exactamente igual
que en estas dos ecuaciones,
ok, vamos a simplificar esta expresión hasta
que se vea muy fácil de resolver.
Entonces, empecemos por pensar en que "s"
la podemos ver como un 1 por "s", cierto,
y entonces podemos factorizar a la "s", o
sea esta cosa de aquí, la podemos ver como
1 "s" multiplicando a 1 menos 3/8, ok, entonces
tenemos aquí y lo vamos a factorizar del
lado izquierdo, "s" por 1...
es este término, "s" por 1...
menos "s" por 3/8, la "s" la dejamos por acá
y ponemos aquí a los 3/8
y todo esto tiene que ser igual a 5/6.
Y bueno, para simplificar este paréntesis,
aquí tenemos un 1 menos 3/8, el 1 lo podemos
ver como 8/8, porque 8 entre 8 es 1
y entonces aquí tenemos 8/8 menos 3/8, eso es 5/8, que está multiplicando a "s"
y eso es igual a 5/6, ok, pudimos haberlo visto desde el principio, teníamos por aquí 1 por "s" menos 3/8 de "s",
eso lo podíamos ver como 8/8 de "s"
menos 3/8 de "s"
y entonces nos quedan simplemente 5/8 de "s".
Y otra vez, hemos llegado a una ecuación
como las del video pasado, tenemos aquí a
nuestra variable por un coeficiente
igual a otro número, entonces vamos a multiplicar
por el inverso de este coeficiente, o sea,
vamos a multiplicar por 8/5, ok, pero todo
lo que hagamos del lado izquierdo,
lo tenemos que hacer también del lado derecho y llega
la hora de la cancelada,
multiplicamos por 8/5 para que este 5 se cancele con este 5 y para que este 8 se cancele con este 8, ok,
pero por acá, este 5 también se cancela
con este 5 y aquí, podemos dividir al 6 entre 2
y entonces nos queda 3 y podemos dividir
al 8 entre 2 y nos queda 4.
Entonces, nos queda que "s" es igual a 4/3.
Entonces aquí tenemos que resolver esta ecuación donde la variable es "q",
¿y tú que dices?
¿se ve como una ecuación complicada o no?
Bueno, con esta ecuación lo que yo quiero hacer es enseñarte que no importa que camino tomemos,
para resolver esta ecuación, para encontrar que valor debe de tener "q" para que se dé esta igualdad,
siempre y cuando realicemos puras operaciones aritméticas válidas y cada que sumemos,
restemos, multiplicamos, dividamos, de un lado del igual, hagamos lo mismo del otro lado del igual,
vamos a llegar exactamente a la misma respuesta, ok.
Vamos a reescribir esta ecuación, tenemos
aquí, 5/12 por "q" menos 7 igual a 2/3
y en el primer camino que yo voy a tomar, lo primero que voy a hacer es multiplicar por el inverso de este número,
ok, de 5/12. Entonces voy a multiplicar por
12/5 de los dos lados del igual,
para seguir preservando esta igualdad, ok,
¿y para que hice eso?
Pues lo hice para que este 12 se cancele con
este 12 y este 5 se cancele con este 5, ok,
sin embargo de este lado del igual también
se van a cancelar algunas cosas,
podemos aquí dividir este 12 entre 3, entonces 12 entre
3 nos queda 4 y este 3 también lo dividimos
entre 3 y nos queda 1y entonces aquí nos
queda, 2 por 4 = 8 entre 1 por 5 = 5.
Así es que lo que nos queda es "q" menos
7 igual a 8/5.
Ahora, lo que queremos es deshacernos de este 7, porque una vez que nos deshagamos de este 7,
nos va a quedar simplemente "q" igual a otro número y entonces ya habremos resuelto esta ecuación, ok.
Esta ya es una ecuación como las del
video pasado ¿no?.
Entonces sumamos 7 de los dos lados del igual,
eso es muy importante,
de este lado, esto lo podemos reescribir como 8/5 más el 7 es exactamente igual a 35/5 y de este lado
pues ¿para qué sumamos el 7?
para que se cancelara con el -7 , ¿no?
o sea, aquí tenemos "q" más 7 menos 7 y eso es igual a "q" más 0 que es simplemente una "q",
ok, que resultó ser igual a 8 más 35, 43/5.
Y listo, esta es nuestra respuesta
siguiendo este camino.
Ahora, lo que vamos a hacer, es resolver esta
ecuación tomando un camino distinto,
ok, entonces empecemos por reescribir
nuestra ecuación.
Tenemos por aquí 5 por "q" menos 7
entre 12 igual a 2/3.
Como que este 12 nos está estorbando por acá, ¿no?
Entonces nos tenemos que deshacer de él y
la mejor forma de deshacernos de un
1 entre 12 es multiplicando por un 12.
Así es que multiplicamos por 12
de los dos lados del igual,
para que éste se cancele con éste.
Y bueno, de este lado, aquí podemos dividir
el 12 entre 3 y de eso nos va a quedar un 4,
entonces aquí, 12 entre 3 es un 4 y aquí
tenemos 2 por 4 = 8,
así es que esta ecuación es equivalente a
5 por "q" menos 7 igual a 8.
Ahora, aquí hay varias cosas que podríamos
hacer, una de ellas sería
deshacernos de este 5 que también se ve que nos está estorbando ¿no?
Pero eso sería muy parecido a lo que hicimos
en este camino, porque si dividimos entre
5 como acabamos de multiplicar por 12, eso
sería igualito a haber multiplicado por 12/5,
entonces en realidad estaríamos siguiendo
este camino que ya hicimos
y queremos hacer uno nuevo, uno distinto.
Así es que pues hay que buscar más opciones.
Pero aquí tenemos una muy buena opción,
aquí en lugar de dividir entre 5,
vamos a distribuir esta multiplicación, este paréntesis,
entonces nos queda 5 por "q" más 5 por -7,
ok, entonces tenemos aquí 5 por "q" menos
5 por 7 = 35 igual a 8.
Ya es una ecuación mucho más sencilla ¿no?
o sea, esta ecuación es exactamente la misma
ecuación que esta otra, pero esta si se ve
mucho más fácil de resolver ¿no?
bueno, ese es el chiste, eso es lo que tenemos
que hacer, simplificar ecuaciones complicadas
quitando las cosas que nos estorben para que
nos queden ecuaciones fáciles de resolver.
Bueno, pero entonces vamos a resolverla ¿no?
Aquí, nos queremos deshacer de este 35
y la forma más fácil de hacer eso es sumando
35 de los dos lados del igual,
entonces nos queda 8 más 35 igual a 43 y por aquí, ¿para qué sumamos 35?
Pues, para que se cancele con este -35.
Entonces nos queda 5 por "q" igual a 43
y esta ya es una ecuación tal cual como las
del video pasado.
Tenemos a la variable que queremos encontrar
por un coeficiente igual a otro número,
entonces podemos simplemente dividir entre el coeficiente de los dos lados del igual, muy importante
y obtenemos la respuesta.
"q" igual a 43/5 y mira nada más,
obtuvimos exactamente la misma respuesta, nos fuimos por dos caminos distintos,
pero hicimos todas las operaciones bien y todo lo que le hacíamos de un lado del igual,
también se lo hacíamos del otro lado del igual y obtuvimos la misma "q".
Bueno, me parece que es hora de hacer
un ejercicio con palabras.
Tanessi fue al centro y gastó casi todo su dinero, solo se quedó con 10 pesos para regresar a su casa.
El taxi cuesta .75 pesos por kilómetro, pero se agrega un costo inicial de 2.35 pesos.
Escribe una fórmula y úsala para calcular cuántos kilómetros puede recorrer en taxi con su dinero.
Y determina cuando kilómetros puede recorrer.
Entonces esa Tanessi,
gastó casi todo su dinero pero tiene 10 pesos, entonces esa Tanessi quiere calcular
¿cuántos kilómetros puede recorrer en taxi
con el dinero que tiene?
aquí pongamos una "c" que represente cuanto cuesta el taxi y por acá nosotros tenemos que el taxi cuesta,
de entrada, cuesta 2.35 pesos nada más
por subirse al taxi,
entonces tiene que pagar 2.35 pesos más .75 pesos por cada kilómetro que recorra,
ok, esta "k" representa el número de
kilómetros recorridos...
"k" es igual al número de kilómetros recorridos...
recorridos...
Pero nosotros sabemos que Tanessi solo tiene
10 pesos para llegar a su casa,
entonces podemos poner aquí, en el lugar del costo del taxi la cantidad de dinero que tiene Tanessi,
entonces tenemos aquí los 10 pesos que
tiene Tanessi y esos 10 pesos
que es lo que le va a costar a Tanessi
tomar el taxi es igual a 2.35 más
dependiendo de cuantos kilómetros recorra .75 por esa cantidad de kilómetros que recorra.
Ok. Y ahora queremos ver cuantos kilómetros puede
recorrer Tanessi con estos 10 pesos,
o sea, queremos encontrar,
¿cuánto vale "k" para que se satisfaga esta ecuación?
Entonces, lo primero que queremos hacer es
deshacernos de este 2.35,
así es que vamos a restar 2.35 de los
dos lados del igual... 2.35...
porque así, éste se cancela con éste y de este lado ya nos queda simplemente la cantidad
de kilómetros que puede recorrer Tanessi
por .75, pero de este lado vamos a sacar la
calculadora para que no tengas que confiar
en que yo haga las cuentas bien...
2.35 negativo más 10 eso es igual a 7.65, ok...
7.65, ok...
esto es esto de aquí, que es igual a .75
por la cantidad de kilómetros que
puede recorrer Tanessi.
Entonces para dejar a la "k" solita lo único
que nos falta es deshacernos de este .75
y la mejor forma de deshacernos de él es dividiendo
entre .75 de los dos lados del igual.
Aquí .75 se cancela con .75 y nos queda simplemente
una "k" que es lo que buscamos y de este lado,
pues vamos a sacar la calculadora otra vez
¿no?
Tenemos aquí 7.65 entre .75 y eso es igual a 10.2...
10.2...
"k" es igual a 10.2.
Así es que Tanessi puede recorrer 10.2 kilómetros
en taxi con los 10 pesos que tiene.
Entonces si se encuentra a menos de 10.2 kilómetros
de su casa, no va a tener ningún problema.